you know a lot of people have been up in
arms recently about the way people with
flight attendants or passengers are
behaving on planes it's a national
conversation you recently tweeted about
something that really happened to you on
a plane can you explain yeah so I'm on a
plane flying from North Carolina back to
LA and a guy I'm here my wife is here
there's a guy here across the aisle and
he gets on the plane and he takes his
pants off he takes his pants off
you know some people take their shoes
off and you're like that's so uncool
yeah he took his pants off and then he
put his Lexie wearing underneath his
pants he's wearing boxers okay and you
know you see he's sitting at the
bulkhead so it's right at the front and
he puts his legs up and you guys are
like no way
show him the picture he took a picture
of this this is the guy that guy and
he's right in the front of the plane so
anybody who walks in is greeted look at
the way his the screen is illuminating
his crotch
like it's a holy relic no you know what
I mean when it when I heard about this I
thought that can't be true and then I
saw the photograph and I thought that's
that's yeah how does someone think they
can do that I don't know I don't know
and he's up front so everybody who comes
in is greeted by this defiant flesh
Eevee everybody has to walk by a
children and I was like what what's
gonna happen well yes someone's gonna
like go and speak to him yeah yeah well
so he's there he's due and he was like
really I noticed this guy before we got
on the plane because he was one of the
guy he was like right in front of the
gate waiting like people with
wheelchairs had to like get around him
as if he was like I can't wait to get on
that plane and get these pants off
so finally awhile goes by towards like
it's been this is about a five-hour
flight so like three hours in and a
fighter name comes up to him and it's
like hey sir could you please put your
legs down oh you think people are going
to the body pin your pants on just put
your legs down yeah we're we're not
looking for home runs here Conan yeah so
she says could you please put your pants
down your legs down and the guy and guy
just looks at her and they have this
totally quiet 40 seconds stare down and
the guy slowly like puts his legs down
while just looking at her yeah five
minutes go by and his he starts putting
one leg back up can we see the picture
that he just like a clenched fist raised
against an unjust sky yeah like got his
leg back up and and then he had that on
for the rest of the flight until they
started descending and they were like
hey put away your tray tables and all
that and if your legs on a wall put that
down
he doesn't do anything he's just sitting
there with one leg up and then like two
minutes before was supposed to hit the
ground he gets up and he slowly puts his
pants back on
sits back down and then he gets off the
plane and there isn't any police waiting
for him or anything and he just walks
into the crowd I don't understand how
you can get away with that and I'm
wondering why I haven't thought of it
before I guess I have long legs and I
like to take my pants off whenever I can
I know me too and I feel like why maybe
I'll do that now if that's okay it's not
it's not don't say yeah it's not okay
who's saying yeah well ladies always
want to get a look at these man pretty
amazing you know you think like you're
gonna like what the situation is right
you gonna like stand up and do something
it was that day I understood I am no
hero
you stood and let it all happen yeah if
some [ __ ] goes down I will tweet about
it
you